hi everyone we are very excited to bring
you a whole new season of fate and
fabled hang tight to the end of this
episode where we'll be revealing a fun
surprise for the upcoming season stay
tuned
gather round you nerds and Weirdos to
hear this epic tale of a Godly War where
each side goes I think we just might
fail in Old Norse lore a witch was
burned not once nor twice but Thrice on
her behalf the wartide turned and each
side paid the price cue years of war
before a fragile piece could be agreed
to one side's anger was Unleashed
misunderstood indeed but wisdom one did
Odin Roar hey spit in this cup here and
thus ended the vicious war between the
asir and the veneer
foreign
how do you end a war between Gods with
spit of course in Norse mythology two
competing groups of gods called the asir
and the veneer fought a devastating War
until they combined their saliva to
cement a remarkably unique truce Divine
Wars aren't rare they can be found in
most mythologies from around the world
the greek olympians fought and defeated
the Titans the Hindu Devas were able to
banish the Demonic asuras to something
that resembled hell and Christian Angels
cast the rebellious demons down into
actual hell these conflicts usually end
with good triumphing over evil a
reminder to us Mortals of what happens
when you stray from the righteous path
but the war between the asir and veneer
is different because it doesn't impose a
moral hierarchy instead the two groups
combined into a single United Pantheon
maybe the Norse just liked some
different story tropes but some Scholars
think this myth can provide insight into
the actual history of Scandinavia how
about we tell you the story and then you
can decide for yourself what it means to
understand enviouser and veneer let's
take a closer look at how Norse
mythology is structured the universe
according to Norse mythology is split up
into nine different worlds resting in
the roots and branches of the great tree
egg dracil each world is inhabited by A
different race like the Giants on
yotenheim and the dwarves on spartalheim
and the wee blue folk of smurfheim okay
I made that last one up but we humans
lived on midgard and worshiped two other
races as Gods the veneer of Anaheim and
the asir of Asgard the veneer used their
powerful magic to help humans prosper in
agriculture wealth and fertility they
were wise thoughtful and wielded a
coveted magic called seder which could
foresee and shape the future
the asir on the other hand were more
interested in violence and War than
their magical counterparts for them
brute strength bravery and loyalty were
valued above most other traits
fail nerd what you doing a gardening
Meathead I'm a veneer I Inspire the
humans and midgard to grow crops and
gain more wealth well I am in a Seer and
I incite the humans towards violence and
War weird Flex I'm pretty sure everybody
get more respect for what I do you would
think that wouldn't you
most sources say the war started as
retaliation for an assyr act of cowardly
violence one section from the poetic
Edda tells us about gulvague a witch
goddess who traveled to Asgard and
shared her magic with the asir she gave
the aseer gifts granted their wishes and
brought prosperity to the all-father
Odin's hall for which the asira were
totally grateful I'm just kidding these
are the gods of violence and War we're
talking about they feared that gold
Vegas generosity was making them soft
and complacent or gold trunk which is
one translation of her name so they
decided to kill her first with Spears
and when that didn't work they burned
her at the stake three times and three
times she was reborn From the Ashes
thanks to her magic they renamed her
heider meaning bright one the texts
don't specify where this powerful woman
came from or what she wanted one
possible theory is that goldwig was a
veneer goddess Freya in Disguise this is
just one moment in the story where it
splits into multiple versions just like
Marvel's many multiverses OB obviously
the veneer couldn't let this treatment
of one of their own go unpunished so
they uncharacteristically readied for
war but the asir were always prepared
for battle so when Odin learned about
the veneer's plans he was able to strike
first
the two groups met on the plane of war
the same field where the final battle in
Ragnarok was predestined to take place
and Odin threw the first spear into
Enemy Lines the ettas and other
remaining records of Norse lore don't
provide many details about the war but
imply that it was devastating for both
sides after the first battle the veneer
used their magic to decimate the
protective walls that encircled Asgard
and later when the gods hire a giant to
rebuild the wall Loki will shape-shift
into a lady horse and distract the giant
stallion so he can't finish the job on
time and won't have to be paid freya's
hand in marriage known as The Bugs Bunny
Gambit it seems like a risky way to get
out of paying a bill
in return the asir absolutely wrecked
the veneer Homestead with the battle
prowess that inspired centuries of
Viking raids War waged for years with
magic and physical strength taking turns
on the upper hand potions bested axes
swords sliced through spells eventually
the two sides realized they were at an
impasse and met to call a ceasefire
well that was what was it yeah I mean
maybe we should join forces with my
bravery and strength your magic we could
be like the best Pantheon ever like the
Justice League Meets the Avengers
I was gonna say Care Bears oh yeah
that's fair in the long-standing
Germanic and Scandinavian tradition each
side cemented the truce by sending some
of their own to live with their former
foes the veneer sent Freya her brother
freyjer and their father njord to live
among the assyr while heiner and Nemer
were sent to live on vanheim the three
veneers settled well into life on Asgard
but heiner and Nemer weren't so
fortunate at first the veneer were so
enchanted by Heiner's good looks and
wisdom that they made him their leader
but when they found out that heiner was
just a dope who was getting his advice
from memer they were so mad that they
cut off mimer's head and sent it to
Daddy Odin Odin used the Seder magic
that veneer taught him to keep meemer's
head alive and thankfully avoided
Another all-out War the decapitation was
written off as nothing more than a
misunderstanding I mean who Among Us
hasn't gotten confused and lopped off a
former enemy's head the assyr and veneer
gathered once more and debated according
to the voluspa poem whether the god
should tribute give or to Allah like
should worship belong the veneer wanted
either compensation for the way goldwag
had been treated or equal worship by the
humans no more of this also featuring
bull the asir agreed to share their
Divine status and the two groups secured
their piece by spitting into a cauldron
from the spit emerge the god kavasir the
wisest of all beings whose blood became
the legendary Mead of poetry we don't
know why spit was used to seal such a
momentous decision but I love that the
practice lives on in the modern spit
Shake to the Sierra and veneer oh wait
why not to the veneer and to Seer it's
alphabetical
uh
so why is the ending to this war so
unique it's possible this story and its
spitty conclusion were merely adopted
and adapted from proto-indo-european
cultures as they intermingled but I'm
personally not convinced the story's
ending is too unlike other myths from
the region instead I agree with
historians like Dr John lindau that this
myth acts as a blurred reflection of
real world events we've talked about
this phenomenon on the show before an
influential person or Local Hero might
be exaggerated into a god like the
Europa King Shango who was deified as an
orisha or a clash of cultures could be
remembered as a legendary war much like
the six invasions described in the Irish
mythological cycle here the hypothesis
is that Germanic tribes migrated North
about 3000 years ago encountered
indigenous Scandinavians with their own
differing Pantheon and Incorporated it
into their own we know that ancient
Germanic tribes worshiped a war god
named woden and Roman records tell us
that they were skilled Fighters so it's
easy to imagine them following the war
hungry aseer Gods but not the
seder-wielding veneer it seems much more
likely that the veneer were worshiped by
indigenous Scandinavians who placed more
of a societal emphasis on connecting to
the land the Sami people native to what
is now Northern Scandinavia had a
shamanic religion before they were
christianized in the 16th century and
their shamanic practices might have been
mythologized as seder their relationship
with the land could have yielded a
Pantheon of veneer-like Agriculture and
fertility deities I say might and could
because unfortunately little is known
about this Region's history due to a
lack of written records and a climate
that tends to destroy archaeological
artifacts regardless of the myth's
origin the war between the assyr and
veneer is a powerful reminder that
conflicts rooted in anger and fear can
still be resolved through wisdom and
mercy in that Spirit we've cooked up a
fun treat for you in this season of fate
and fabled Dr mcti and I have each
picked five of our favorite figures from
mythology it's kind of like a fantasy
football draft but without all the toxic
competition we'll reveal one of our
choices in each thematically appropriate
episode and at the end of the season
we'll unite our pantheons just like the
Nords did so to start us off Dr mctee
who's your first pick oh I'm so excited
for you to hear this I am choosing do
you know it done no it done is uh Anna
Seer she's a goddess of fertility and
spring and Rejuvenation but she is in
charge of planting the golden apples
that the asir used to Stay immortal and
beautiful that sounds like something I
want so I definitely approve of this
pick thank you I do like the option of
living forever so I wanted to give the
people in our little Utopia that option
and the more gold the better in my book
exactly
[Music]
excellent first pick to start us off
I'll be making my first pick of the
pantheon at the end of The Next Episode
but make sure you stay tuned for every
episode this season we'll reveal our
Pantheon picks at the end of each but
maybe you'll remember that better in
verse is there any of that poetry Mead
left yes
there you go thank you
ten God's chosen five a piece from the
world around in sky or sea or deep dark
pit could they all be found we'll share
the tales of people whose lives our
choices touched and set aside the
differences that once they may have
clutched so stick around this season we
promise you won't yawn once you see who
we draft in our fantasy Pantheon
hey Foodies you're missing out if you're
not watching the new stuff cooking over
on PBS food go on a tasty journey to
find the best South Asian food in
America on spice Road or get ready to
swap delicious recipes from different
cultures on pan Pals the channel has
shows covering the history of iconic
dishes to food science hit the link in
our description to check them out just
don't watch these on an empty stomach
I would wear this outfit though
I low-key would actually probably wear
this yeah wait why not to the vasir and
the inir that's not what they're called
oh